all right I want to make sure everybody
can hear me okay so raise your hand if
you're currently a data scientist and if
you're looking to hire a data scientist
and if you want a job as a data
scientist okay good so this is mostly
for people who are thinking about hiring
data scientists but it's going to be
very relevant to those of us who are
also looking for a job and if you are
currently a data scientist it might help
you think about how to define your role
and sorts of you know what else you
might want to learn how to do I'm coming
from a research background and when I
went to look for my first data scientist
position I talked to a hiring manager
who is very nice about saying well you
don't need to know that much Python
because we pair our scientists with
engineers so I went in to do the
interview and my strengths were at that
time really an ad hoc analysis and they
said you need to learn more Python so I
went home and I learned more Python and
I went to another interview and they
said can you do a coding exercise in
Excel and I said I don't want a job
writing excel so I went to another
interview and they said can you do this
really complex sequel query no I didn't
know how to do that so i went home and
learned more sequel i went to another
interview they asked me about
multithreading and really high-level
python things like decorators I wouldn't
learn more Python came back did another
interview and they quizzed me on
statistics I wasn't very good at doing
pop quizzes I've never have been i'm
still not i went to another interview
and they started quizzing me on machine
learning so i was finding overall here
are my observations first of all I can't
iterate on this process there was almost
nothing in common from one interview to
the next even the questions that you
might think would be typical what's a
normal distribution very rarely God
asked that question the sorts of things
they tell you to prep
almost never got asked those um if there
was a pattern I was having a hard time
figuring out what it was and I felt like
a lot of these companies were using the
interview process to try to decide what
they wanted because they really hadn't
thought about it ahead of time um right
so as much as I was trying to sample
companies they were trying to sample
candidates and they didn't seem to know
where to begin so when I went back and
did a sort of a pseudo analysis looking
at my notes and thinking about what
questions were in common and there were
only two types of roles where it really
seemed like there was any consistency
one was an analyst position where they
really always asked you about sequel and
the other was at the other extreme where
it was a software engineering position
and they pretty much always asked you to
do whiteboarding everything else was a
mix and fairly frequently I was asked
are you sure you want to be a data
scientist or are you sure you wouldn't
consider this other role so I really
want to talk today about how data
science spans this whole spectrum um
everything from an analyst who maybe
doesn't know how to code it all but is
perfectly fine working with a bunch of
data that's already clean to someone
who's maybe a software engineer who's
very comfortable writing algorithms and
everything in between where a lot of us
are really somewhere in between and what
you actually want if you're trying to
hire a data scientist is someone who can
generate insights someone who
understands the scientific process
they're comfortable asking questions and
trying to figure out how do we address
the problem that's never been solved
before so I volunteered to give this
talk partly because I'm coming from a
research background where we regularly
interview people and I was kind of
shocked at how the software industry
does this because it's so different from
what I was coming from um so from my
perspective if you have to interview
someone and you can't give them a test
there's three things you can do that are
very easy one is that you look at their
work product right you ask them to show
you a portfolio of the work they've done
in the past the second is they might ask
you questions and that's maybe even more
important than the
you're asking them have they really
thought about this role are they capable
of narrowing down what makes this role
different from some other role and can
they tell you a story can they define a
problem explain how they addressed it
and talk about the possible pitfalls and
how they address them so I'm going to
talk about the pitfalls that I've seen
in the software industry interview
process for data science um it basically
spans again a spectrum from under
specifying the role to over specifying
the role so if you under specify the
role I think what typically happens is
somebody says we need to hire a data
scientist and they don't know what that
means right and they probably hand off
that job to someone who's maybe an
engineer maybe someone who doesn't even
know statistics and now they're tasked
with interviewing someone and they don't
really know where to begin so in those
cases you might end up with a very
open-ended problem they might give you a
dump of data and say tell us what our
data means right which is great except
it's not clear what they're looking for
and frequently they don't know and that
means they don't know how to evaluate
what you've given them and they're going
to be comparing apples and oranges when
people submit wildly different kinds of
solutions to here's what I found in your
data so i would argue that if you're
going to do that kind of thing it makes
you look like as a company you haven't
really prioritized the types of
questions you want answered and you
didn't really put the time into planning
what are we trying to interview for and
the other end is the stats pop quiz
where they might say here's an extremely
vague scenario what would you do if we
gave you two data sets and you had to
tell them apart or something and I've
actually had interviews like this where
I said can you give me more information
can you tell me the distribution of the
data can you tell me how many times the
data was sampled how frequently and
they're like no just tell us what you
would do
and I'm going that's not how you would
actually do this right so they want me
to read their mind about some other
piece of information or their business
context that I can't possibly know so
again I would say this is the inability
to think as a hiring manager from the
perspective of the candidate they don't
have access to all the things that you
know so if you're going to give them
these kinds of questions you need to
give them enough context to understand
why you're asking and then the other end
of the spectrum is over specifying the
role these are the people who think they
want only someone who's done exactly a
certain thing and peter wang talked
about this briefly in his talk yesterday
i want someone who's done spark right
scala we want scala Scala's hot the
problem is next year Scala is going to
be out date so you know the question is
why are you asking me this did you not
read my CV did you not believe my CV or
are you hoping that even though this
thing wasn't on my CV that maybe I have
actually done it so like for example if
you've worked in a proprietary setting
you may have all kinds of interesting
projects that you're not really allowed
to discuss so they're not on your github
and in that case asking this kind of
question can be useful because you can
have an opportunity to maybe talk
vaguely about a story or a type of
technique you views that was relevant
but this kind of question again it tends
to narrow the field so much that you
might be weeding people out who could
learn X thing very quickly but just
because they haven't done it before it
doesn't mean that you shouldn't continue
talking to them and then the are you
sure you're not willing to do some other
role and often with the bait of but
you'd be around other people who are
doing data science or we might have a
need for a data scientist in six months
and this kind of thing maybe we think
you're not really qualified but we like
you we want to offer you some
entry-level position that we
think you might be comfortable doing or
we have a lot of data but we know it's
not useful to be analyzed yet because we
really need someone to clean it up are
you sure you're not willing to do the
data engineering or we're really just
looking for smart people we'd be happy
to slot you into a software engineer
position you seem like you're smart as
long as you're willing to work hard and
again this can kind of over specify the
role this can mean that you're taking
someone who's expressed a certain
interest in a certain type of role and
you're trying to shoehorn them into
something else so those kinds of
interviews often include many levels of
jump through flaming hoops answer a
trick quoting question how much sequel
do you know can you do live coding with
no syntax highlighting or any kind of
reference material and my personal
favorite the language agnostic pair
programming exercise um bottom line it's
not language agnostic if it's not in
Python if you've told them python is
your main language and they want you to
interview in java there's some trick
that you need to know that's java
specific that python takes careful of
for you right and they're going to judge
you that you didn't know that trick even
though they told you the interview was
language agnostic and they'll say that
it's pair programming but it's not there
the person that you're working with is
evaluating you and they're not going to
give you any help with the question so
again I feel like a lot of times these
interviews come from a place of totally
unrealistic expectations because they're
not really thinking about what is the
data scientists do they're coming from a
history of we've analyzed how to
interview an analyst and how to
interview a software engineer and we
still don't really know how to interview
a data scientist so I have some
suggestions first of all don't use the
interview to randomly sample candidate
space and I think this often the
tell-tale sign is when the job
description
is not clear or if it's really over
ambitious and it's a giant list of
skills that's a sign that the company
either isn't sure what they want or
there's multiple people who want
different things and I wrote a blog post
a while back about when the recruiter
and the hiring manager and the team all
have different ideas about what sort of
candidate they should be interviewing
the job description is often a way to
tell if that's going to be a problem so
I'm going to say if you're writing a job
description and also as a candidate you
know think about this what are the
really essential things about this role
Python maybe nice things to have it be
great if you've done Django right or
bonus points if you've also done some
JavaScript or whatever but really you
want to match the interview questions to
the role and so it helps to go back and
look at the job description again before
you decide what the interview is going
to consist of so the seven types of
interviews then if you look the whole
spectrum there's some overlap in most of
these categories right starting all the
way at the top with the alchemist right
the person who can code any algorithm
that you could possibly need and
optimize it going back to the other end
of the spectrum the person who's
perfectly happy doing an analysis and
talking to business people right someone
who can build a database from scratch
someone who can run statistics and tell
you how meaningful your metrics really
are did you actually see a difference in
that av-test right someone who's
perfectly happy building the pipelines
and cleaning the data and they don't
necessarily want to do the analysis
they're not going to get bored doing the
data cleaning as opposed to someone who
really does want to be doing analysis
and predictions and they don't mind
doing some data cleaning but it's
probably not their main job or the
person that you bring in when your data
is a mess and you know it and you don't
know what went wrong
and they can look at a giant pile of
data and tell you this is what this data
means so think about where these
different roles fit in the data stack
right where do you want to be in the
data stack and what does your data stack
really need right so start at the
beginning let's say your brand new
company you're designing schema for a
brand new database you have to clean the
data you have to pipeline it maybe from
some outside API you're going to have to
be able to query it with some sequel
you're going to do some analysis on it
you're going to do some visualization
and show it to your business people your
investors all that kind of stuff you're
going to want to do some statistics now
you can finally you have some data
you're going to query it maybe you're
going to want to optimize it at some
point later maybe you're going to want
to do some predictions going forward so
where do these rules fit right you've
got someone who's your rock solid I can
make a database from the ground up
you've also got someone who can go in
and look at your database and figure out
what to do with it maybe you don't have
any data science yet you've got someone
who's perfectly happy to do the
pipelining and they're going to get in
there and get dirty and figure out how
to make all these different API is play
well together business inspector a
person I've mentioned several times
they're in a different place they're
really doing a lot of visualizations
they're good with color and design and
they know how to present something so
that it's simple and accessible to a
non-technical crowd whereas your
algorithms Alchemist they probably never
want to talk to the business people
right they want to go hide in a corner
somewhere and write and crunch that's
all they want to do so and your
probability wizard maybe they'll talk to
the business people some they're gonna
do a bunch of math they write some code
but they don't want to write tests they
don't they're not really interested in
making things production eyes right and
maybe you've got people who can kind of
sit in the middle somewhere there and
they're able to make predictions and
maybe they're okay with production izing
maybe that's not really their cup of tea
so you know looking at all of the skill
set and sort of everything that's in the
data stack and where it fits inside your
app and all the different maybe
microservices of your company you might
want a bunch of data scientists you're
probably not going to find one person
who excels it all of these things so you
know you might want to think about do
you want to have someone who can do the
bottom or the top or a generalist you
can kind of do everything until you can
add more people and I think we should
really be thinking about evaluating
candidates the same way we evaluate
employees and this is also an area that
needs a lot of improvement obviously you
can't necessarily look at the number of
commits of a candidate but it might help
if you looked at their portfolio their
github something are they people who
work steadily are they people who
procrastinate and then make a whole
bunch of commits all the night before
and if you have interview questions that
are trick questions ask your current
employees do they know the trick I
actually witnessed this happen in one of
the opposite that I worked in where
someone said oh I love asking this
question and it was a trick question and
most of the people at the company didn't
know the trick so I think if you have to
give a hint it's probably not a good
interview question it's fun maybe if
you're into that sort of thing but it's
probably not a good way to evaluate a
candidate and I think some of us know
about this recent study was highlighted
google had an article in The New York
Times about this and there was a TED
talk about it last year the idea of
psychological safety is really important
you want your candidate to feel it
comfortable showcasing their skills and
if you make them uncomfortable because
you think that pressure testing them is
going to tell you something about their
performance you're going to miss out on
a lot of really good candidates who are
never going to work in a high-stress
situation similar to
this artificial interview process that
you've created also whoops I'm sorry I
didn't mean to do that um it really
helps to match the wording of the
question to the intent make it really
clear what you're trying to ask so for
example I used to interview a lot of
junior people so like an undergraduate
or a brand new graduate student didn't
really help to ask them why do you want
to work here the answer was always
because I really need a job right it
wasn't there weren't they didn't know
what you wanted to know what you really
wanted to know was how did you find out
about this particular job and which part
of it really excites you right why are
you interested in this role and if they
didn't have any relevant experience that
was okay right we really wanted people
who had common sense and who could
follow directions so you look for things
like do you have equivalent skills from
some other part of the world right maybe
you've never used a pipette but you do
know how to cook um maybe you've never
worked in the lab before but we want you
to take care of the frogs and it turns
out you worked in a pet store that's
fine we know you can follow directions
and keep frogs alive right so you know
if you can think of analogous skill sets
that can actually really helped a lot
you can also look for other things like
is the person taking notes while you're
talking to them that can tell you a lot
on the other end of the spectrum if
you're interviewing a PhD don't ask them
have you ever worked on a difficult
project because the answer is always yes
really what you want to know is you know
tell me about your research experience
tell me how this is relevant to your
interest in being a data scientist
another question I got a lot I still get
is you know are you sure you want to
leave biology even though I left several
years ago right I don't I think as an
interview where it's not really your job
to try and project assumptions on to the
candidate right don't don't try and
guess about their
motivation really what you want to know
is what interests you right what how can
we take advantage of your skill set and
work well together so I have some
suggestions for types of questions that
I think maybe we can't avoid them maybe
we just need to think about a better way
to ask them anything you could memorize
or look up it's probably not a great
interview question so you know
personally do I know what a t-test is
yes I've published several corresponding
author papers where we primarily use
things like T tests can I give you a
textbook definition of it in an
interview setting probably not so really
you know you think you're selecting for
someone who's an expert in this area but
actually what you're selecting for is
people who are good at memorizing an
answer and then spitting it back out
again so it doesn't tell you whether
they're going to be able to solve a new
problem or if they know how to look
something up when they haven't done it
before and I was actually really
surprised to notice this difference
between save the science background in
the software background and noticed a
lot of my co-workers who came from a
software background when they ran across
something I hadn't done before their
first inclination was to go to the
command line and just try some [ __ ]
right um where is most of the scientists
the first thing they do is go to google
and look it up someone done this before
do i need to reinvent the wheel here and
I you know you guys are laughing but I
think depending on where you're coming
from there's people who will be
horrified if they see that you went to
stack overflow to look for the syntax of
how to sort a dictionary on the value
because you can never remember that you
have to import operator and its item get
her or something right so you know think
about where is this candidate coming
from they might know how to use Stack
Overflow effectively because they're
trying to save time or they might be a
sort of person who's just kind of
randomly trying to steal answers from
around the internet and they don't
really understand how to put these
pieces together
so I think this is why people want to
ask these kinds of questions to
understand if people really know how to
put the pieces together another kind of
question that I think is common is to
ask about a problem that your team found
really difficult you're hoping to hire
someone who knows how to solve this
problem you figured it out but it took
you a really long time and the problem
with this is best case scenario you're
going to find someone who has done this
exact problem before but again it
doesn't tell you whether they're going
to know what to do in a new situation
and worse than that it's kind of a
lose-lose because either you're going to
be annoyed that they knew the answer
that it took you so long to find or
they're just not going to know and
they're going to feel like how could
they possibly know me you know expect me
to know how to answer this they didn't
know how to answer it either so you know
these kinds of questions sound like a
good idea but again it's probably not
going to be a scenario that sets people
up for success um and I'm going to take
home data question I think is a great
idea but you have to bear in mind that
it makes certain assumptions right in
order to do well on this kind of a
challenge you have to have the time and
money right it really does select for
people who can set aside a day or
weekend and they either have a pretty
new laptop or they've used AWS and they
know how to run things remotely and it's
often times it's just not clear what
they're looking for so I think the ones
that are the least effective or where
the requirements are unclear and the
people who asked the question the hiring
managers make themselves completely
unavailable after giving the assignment
here's the assignment on a Friday
afternoon no one's going to answer email
all weekend tell us about our data right
or and afterwards they refuse to discuss
your answer with you so if you're going
to do this kind of thing make it close
the circle right make it a real
collaborative
process something that simulates what it
would be like to be in the office with
these people on beyond slack answer
questions and talk to them afterwards
even if you didn't understand their
answer you thought it was messy or they
just panicked and only finished half of
it because it'll be a really good
learning experience for everyone about
whether this was a good question did you
give them so much data that they
couldn't handle it on their laptop was
the data so dirty that they spent 48
hours cleaning it and two hours
analyzing it is that really what you
wanted them to spend their time on think
about these kinds of things before you
ask these kinds of questions and also
babe bear in mind you may think that
your unbiased about what kinds of
answers people are going to come up with
but you're not this is your data this is
your company you've thought about these
problems a lot more than they have you
actually have some idea of what sorts of
responses you're expecting and probably
what you're going to end up doing is
selecting for people who think exactly
like you do they're going to do exactly
the thing that you expected them to do
so you know keep that in mind if you're
going to ask these kinds of questions do
you want someone who's going to do the
expected thing the machine learning
algorithm that you think is the perfect
type of classifier that's if that's
really what you think you want done
that's great but you at that point you
might as well just ask them to write
that classifier the questions that I
think are really good are again these
ones that really simulate the day to day
so what is this code do I think these
ones are great where someone gives you
some piece of code maybe it does or does
not have docstrings maybe the names of
the methods are obvious or not because
it shows the candidate what your code
looks like also and if they can't look
at a new piece of code and talk through
ok so we're instantiate asab ject and
we're initializing it with these
attributes and now we've got these
methods on it we're going to go and get
this data and talk through that then you
know they're not
comfortable with the language you didn't
have to have them do any white boarding
at all and you know what their level
actually is with something like Python
similarly if you give them a script that
you know has a couple of bugs in it I
think this is a great interview question
because it's the sort of thing you end
up doing in real life right inheriting
some legacy code that's broken it may or
may not have tests and see you know can
this candidate figure out how do they go
about debugging something again I think
it's great if you can have them present
a data story the drawback to this
approach is that they have to have
something they can present so if they're
coming from a company where they're not
allowed to present what they worked on
it's kind of a problem you might have to
give them time to come up with the
project so that one it can be you know
hit or miss depending on a candidate
whether they can really commit the time
to work on something like that and if
you're going to ask you know a specific
kind of what would you do in X scenario
type of question try to be as specific
as you can about the real problems that
you face in your company and you know i
love these questions about what would
you do with sparse data or like the talk
yesterday about unbalanced
classifications that's the sort of stuff
you run into in the real world and I
feel like if you can have that kind of
discussion with a candidate or with the
team that you're thinking about joining
that's going to tell you a lot about how
you're going to work together on real
problems that aren't you know pre-baked
or already clean and i think that's it
i'm going to stop and take questions
thank
thank you very much now we're going to
take questions actually presentation
Arthur is really good and I like your
categorization or subcategory sation of
data scientists and do you think if
people are interviewing for data
scientist roles they should maybe start
using these titles instead of data
scientist because just so broad and
everyone seems really a scientist these
days yeah I think we really should think
carefully about what are these roles
because I i run into even within um you
know data engineering what does that
mean right in some cases it means
someone who's a software engineer who
knows how to handle statistics or they
know what to do with data but in other
cases it turns out what they actually
wanted was someone who's DevOps right
they wanted someone who knew how to spin
up AWS and redshift and and they think
that's a data engineer and maybe this
person doesn't know anything about data
so yeah I think we need to think about
you know a finer grain of you know what
are these roles and you know not all
companies are gonna be able to hire
seven people to handle their whole data
stack but yeah I think splitting it into
smaller pieces might be helpful my
question has to do with the progression
of a data science interview so you gave
some great suggestions for questions to
ask things to do in my experience
there's usually like a HR screening and
then maybe some kind of live Q&A over
the phone coding then you go on side or
have a day to take home challenge then
you go on site based on kind of your
suggestions what do you see is a good
cadence so like how many steps do you
think there should be in a data science
interview and then what kind of how
should you progress through the kinds of
questions you ask it each step I think
that's a great question um could you
repeat the question so in terms of how
how you progress through a data science
interview process what should the steps
be so I think the take-home data
challenge is not a bad way to go the HR
screen
fine usually I think it's basically just
a you know can you converse it doesn't
even have to be anything about your
skills I think the only problem with
that screen often is that they typically
have a list of have you done X and they
don't know what X is so if you've done
something equivalent they don't know
what that means so you could get
filtered out at that stage just based on
resume mismatch or something and then I
think the you know if you're going to go
on site after a data challenge that's
probably the best I think doing those
three steps might be okay right talk
talk to someone either HR or the hiring
manager and then do your day to
challenge and then go on site and
discuss your solution and maybe discuss
some other things with the team I think
the ones that I've done that we're
really frustrating i had a couple where
i did a coding challenge they went
really well they liked my solution we
never discussed it and then they wanted
me to do a live coding challenge after
that over the phone and I was like I'm
local your local did you look at my
coding challenge why did I spend half a
day writing this code for you and we're
not even going to talk about it so I
think you know really thinking about you
know do you trust this if you're going
to give someone a take-home challenge
you have to figure out how you're going
to assess you believe that they wrote
this code themselves if you don't
believe that or you're worried about
that then maybe do the phone challenge
instead don't do both of those because
that's just a waste of time in my
opinion so if you look at it from the
business perspective typically to get
value they they really need three people
they need the data engineer who knows
how to open red share convert occur and
all of that stuff they need the data
scientists and then they need the
analyst so every successful data project
typically means these three roles so
have you ever found companies being
honest and saying look we need these
three roles but we don't want to spend
the money for these
three-year-old so we're trying to find
the one unicorn who can do all three
right and then secondly expectations
because guess what the real world data
is dirty so 75 percent of the time you
spend your time as a data janitor and
twenty five percent is when you spend it
as a data scientists actually doing
algorithms first you have to get the
data clean so you can work on it so if
you found people being like the
conversation on site of both candidates
and the interviewers honest about this
these two aspects um I think yes and no
I think a lot of startups around here
would love to have three people the
analysts the engineer and the data
scientist and there may be hoping they
can get by with one person who is both
the data engineer and the data scientist
on the other end of the spectrum you
have people who maybe they already have
some stuff in a database and they want
to go cheap so they're going to get an
analyst skip the data scientist right
it's much cheaper to buy still one
straight out of college and they just
use Excel and that's fine so I think you
know depending on so many factors yes
expectations and how the company is
growing how much time they have right
because you want someone ideally either
to set up a really robust pipeline so
the data is getting cleaned as it's
going through so then your data
scientist and your analysts can just
take the data and do stuff with it right
or you give them a bunch of dirty data
that you've just dumped in a pool
somewhere and you expect them to build
that into their timeline that they're
going to spend most of their time
cleaning and a tiny fraction of their
time thinking thanks this is great these
are pretty dysfunctional use cases
you're thrown out here but I'm wondering
in your 30 samples of interviews how
endemic do you think this is you know
what percentage would you just kind of
hearest
they just guess is you know how bad is
this a problem so your question is how
many companies really fall into this
yeah trap I don't know I would say most
honestly I yeah I'm not going to try and
put a number on it I think there's a lot
of times where there's multiple teams at
a company that do different kinds of
data science and then you get into an
even bigger mess right because now
you've got two teams at the company who
are actually kind of competing with each
other over who gets to do what and it
might be just the luck of the draw which
team you end up interviewing for and
what their process looks like and it's
that really a good fit I don't know and
who you get right I have a friend the
fizzbuzz and tensorflow guy have you
seen his talk and he likes to say that
we're all just coins right your coin
flip on any given day you might be the
best version of yourself for the worst
version right and so you go to an
interview and they flip you five times
and if you're lucky you get an offer
right but it's just you don't know who
you're going to be meeting with that day
whether you're going to really
communicate well what sort of question
they're gonna ask you if you've seen it
before you know I think it's a difficult
problem how do you really select the
right candidate but I also think with
experience and really thinking carefully
about what do we need here on rather
than the kind of like oh we're going to
cover our eyes and do what everybody
else does software engineer let's do
whiteboarding solution it doesn't have
to be that hard well questions so
Samantha that's it that's it thank you
very much thank you all